oi oi e aí galera que assistiu na altura
vocês mas só tive show aqui em recife
olha que beleza nem joga imagem na tela
a guiné domínio e fez um bom estoque
hoje é dia 18 e amanhã 19 em caruaru tem
ingresso na 2ª seção gaivota' primeiro
dia 15 em joão pessoa achou ronaldo joga
no meu de tudo o que já pensa muito bom
e se você já pensou em quem comparecer
ao show da várias risadas legais é só
clicar no primeiro link na descrição do
vídeo é nóis sim e assistir ao público o
que é que as pessoas as pessoas são
preconceituosas duda pessoal na época o
o nome é homem fume
agora no entanto a mãe tudo a pessoa boa
a dificuldade não é pm formiga porque
não vai ter hoje eu sou um barato eu
assistia apostar porque gostando o do
maranhão a tomar é legal porque
científica [ __ ] ou ufo miguel poxim no
city sabe o que eu confesso a vocês que
eu também tinha preconceito eu tinha
preconceito que eu pensava o fumin o que
é que eu fui me faz que é interessante a
quem eu sou ruim ficar acéfala isso que
você não sabe o que é a vida da formiga
na formiga ela tem a força de três
homens engraçados que nunca vi formiga
fazendo supino reto na academia logo
pensar meu deus isso não vai ter o quê
do minuto de duração porque há como é
fácil e tem no mundo e matar a fome que
o superman foi o que matou supermicro
bonita a criptonita ou pedra preciosa
que tira as forças superman mattos pmn
com a arma fatal para matar a fome um
copo de suco 4 cópia isso pede um filme
que ele morreu afogado e um cara que
matasse um filme de um copo de suco
ainda destacou a boa porque ele bebia aí
golear a roma antiga que minha avó deles
que formiga é bom a [ __ ] é vaé porquê
de se soltar cheguei fume da mãe bebê
não ficavam para a vista embaçada que
envolvem 70 anos faz é perguntando que
ela vai me soou com fome dizendo que a
boa vista quando elano está aproveitando
a sua perna da minha roupa pode ver uma
cadeira pode ter um ímã pan e ainda lida
e java dessa cadeira de montar aqui no
meio da casa nem gritos de fora canetas
formiga é que o reino animal então um
certo preconceito porque eles vêm chegue
poderá formiga consegue carregar o peso
três vezes maior que seu peso aí o cara
vai
mija no gol mesmo muito o gato consegue
pegar um passarinho uma velocidade de 80
km por hora da ump no ar ele joga pra
cima e nem ficar em pé vai atravessar
uma rua mostra o que ela quer dizer
muito bom na boca e morre na comarca
bosta que vem aí beleza vou assistir um
filme meu deus a campeã foi na minha
vida por estar a dormir na minha casa
está gravando um vídeo - família todos
pediram e foi um vídeo você pode fazer
show agora disso me esqueceu que te
botou lá em cima pouco a pouco entra em
depressão há cortando os pulsos é quando
o prédio é escutando pablo é o grau
final da depressão até doente escutou
paulo morreu depois de tentar gravando
vídeos fundo eu assisti o homem formiga
na verdade que estou fazendo isto é
passando eu tenho carinho do meu tom no
cinema para assistir um homem formiga
passava do treino o atacante tanto
passar uma pessoa na minha frente para
sentar de música a gente não vá assistir
o filme seja um domingo não aí começou o
filme meu deus não é o homem o homem
bosta é a tudo bem não me fume começou a
história de que vai buscar estudando é
oscar estudando um modo de fazer as
continue para poder conseguir entender o
invade pequenos ficaram de entrar em
todos os lugares caí nos copos de suco
sa a apfn tudo o que acontece os cara
resolveu abortar oscar resolveu abortar
uma criança não abortasse as pesquisas
porque tava pensando assim a passagem de
criar a gente vai criar um esse negócio
vai dar uma merda nunca recriar essa
merda vai dar uma guerra até ser gago
nuclear ainda testará paralela de um
cara que conseguiu invadir o sistema
mais seguro do mundo do [ __ ] de asa
para poder pegar um dinheiro e devolver
às pessoas foram à barra e foi preso ea
mulher perdeu a filha perdeu tudo o cara
ficou na média ele ficou o tipo 1 é ter
depressão e morreu em risco tanto papo
só que aí o cara consegue retomar a
pesquisa e criar a mesma roupa que um
cara primeiro tinha criado aí o cara
pessoas e ficar a criança
e essa merda é uma merda aí também o que
ele fez op então ok esse caso de
conseguir invadir o sistema de segurança
não sei que lá no tanque sem ser visto o
cara pegou ele botou pra usar a roupa do
homem formiga papo de roubar a outra
roupa não estão levando vez que já
pensou a [ __ ] o cateter eu disse olha
a gente quer dar segurança daquilo que
vai ter que entrar vai ter que pegar um
negócio está localizado neste lugar aqui
e mostro no mapa aí vai buscar legal
chega lá onde é no quartel general dos
vingadores meu irmão é qualquer um
quinto nem os vingadores às vezes
conseguem estar no lugar do jogador o
toque do lado de fora por não conseguir
entrar hoje por chegam aqui é que está a
dirigir aquele cara da rasa do
desembargador que ligam que a voa negão
que a rua meu irmão abriram o número do
carro negócio tiver que mudar pode ficar
se á um homem fume e bater num caso o
homem o milho formiga uma amiga que
morrem o suco batendo no carro desligado
e comércio para voar com o relatado à
fome do meu amigo de você caminhará da
formiga difícil agora vou à atrás de um
novo aed difícil demais primeiro que eu
nunca fui at birth to the bone detonada
filme cresce do meu tamanho e diminui
cresce no irmão genial essa [ __ ]
homem-formiga entra dentro da roupa do
caso vingador e quebra o circuito cara
fica doido tremendo e caixa o único miga
entender a roupa do carlos vitor
consegue estado da rua dos casos nunca e
eu não eu mal consigo está bem dessa
roupa que uma baleia o careca da roupa
do caso na toma o teu cu cara rapaz é
muito a paz eu sei lado de um cara que
conversa com as formigas ou mandando
entre o príncipe que o pescoço aquela
fosse o nenê a fome vai lá e pega mas o
cara voa no ru miga e bacca cai toma ele
manda na aproveitar gato tempo tem uma
turminha toda a escola a essa que é a
minha turma essa é minha gang essa é
minha grande emoção humana beleza
a rede gente olha já imagino tem um
exército de formigas meu amigo que eu ia
mandar de fumigar congresso nacional não
era pouco não fiquei imaginando um show
de wesley safadão um mar de fome agora
se sair no jornal açúcar
eu com medo foi amarrado com um absurdo
o filme é muito bom é impressionante
prova muito boa de bancos e também não
ficar o filme chegará quando eu assisti
se quiser falar é assim muito obrigado a
assistir se viu até aqui você vai gostar
você já sabe né é bom e velho gostei que
o youtube ajuda de mais gente é muito
importante você clicou stay para
explodir esse botão de lá que agora e
para me ajudar também se pode volta lá
no facebook você pode lá no meu facebook
eu postei esse vídeo e curti lá também
que isso me ajuda demais
a rim novo senai e até queimar seus
amigos e clicar em curtir e marca um
amigo em baixa e por lá se já tivesse
tido comigo se ainda fosse estivesse ele
gosta
valeu pelo carinho da galera em joão
pessoa dia 15 ou torre vídeo é nóis se
inscreve no canal para não perder nenhum
vídeo e valeu ebr